cows go man my name is welcome back to
more jazzpunk
jesseman Punk oh I didn't mean to do
that
hey looks like here now come on where's
the last one our fourth degree burns all
over my entire face oh it burns action
Tina
ah and SIA fourth-degree burns all over
my entire face ah it burns I want to go
back to DJing that was like the [ __ ] man
okay I can't do it any website I lost I
lost my said I lost my son I don't want
to I don't know what to do while I am
again Wilde's keep playing against like
a school
hey girl with it you wanna play twister
with a man with no feet or arms who said
that it's a catfish get it oh there's an
actual kick what the [ __ ] what is this
[ __ ]
Oh God I get to plan skinhead must
contain was to contain yes yes yes do it
mine mine mine meow oh my god so much
money ruin all the expensive [ __ ] ah
this Philip who would pay that much for
a pillow
five hundred bags for that was worth it
go away what beer money for [ __ ] free
open ice banana I'll save this for later
alligator skater hater mayor a god I
gotta get all the points this is like
Pokemon except not at all from the [ __ ]
I get away get away get away get away
get away get away now look away or the
gray or the gray in my own power
how sometimes try to make Jellison did
that Haven make sense yeah there you go
you loved what all right how do I reach
up there I'm a kitty cat I should be
able to jump in check
oh my god you look expensive come on I
got the car right you dust carpet
covered now snuffle munching candy cane
much that's fun let's do that again
what do you want you don't talk to me Oh
like you
what's with a tank with sharks that's
pretty badass actually what's it say
entanglement this game that tides you up
in Gordian knots that can't be good
right right right hand red
all right well [ __ ] me I'll take this
right yellow may I say my feet look
quite fabulous well I go there all right
well I guess it's better there red yes
that but I don't have [ __ ]
I hate we're not happy when I fought
West man God [ __ ] you know
highlight plot twist I actually liked it
no no no no all right well now I buy
them so be like you all the time
uh-huh contractor don't keep the lawyers
at bay okay that's that makes them don't
find me or not everybody right here oh
yeah well I don't normally like to eat
children
that's why you can't put a price on
trash yachting oh you got any right now
I don't you're not getting enough rats
your diet hides
Trey got a price on Spike ma you can't
put a price up no no no don't go go go
don't tell me what I can and cannot do
what's the word
I will [ __ ] kill you that's the word
yeah that did it
don't try to swizzle your way out of
this okay you're gonna [ __ ] I don't
feel it because are we okay I will
[ __ ] kill you if you do that [ __ ]
again okay guard stop like I got me well
your hand general what you doing hello
quick well your stop taking a third
running board
I don't care what if I get your god damn
god damn sit Oh
all right Wes with what what what Oh
fruits in yeah get out of here fruit
ninja god yeah god damn I miss ours mr.
melon lemonade there we go okay yes
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] lemonade man I miss -
I'm sorry I'd probably get an
achievement I want to [ __ ] get it
what the banana is still Sarah that's
like that Alice Moni
oh if all that okay trihard face
Oh what am I supposed to [ __ ] get
that I don't [ __ ] me okay
I don't take very kindly to it you know
I [ __ ] zing them like that and then
you throw one down here you throw like a
girl who's throwing anyway I'm probably
throwing them with my dick that's funny
that's [ __ ] funny bags
holy [ __ ] satellites god damn that
talking funny man what are you even
doing up stop hiding from me up there
there you go
lemon corked choked I got 12 where's my
achievement I don't even get I don't
even get a G why do you why did I just
do that
alright let's find the hugging bass
there he is psycho right that's cool
okay ah [ __ ]
what are you doing here holes more proof
uh you don't have faces kind of ellebra
I said I can't [ __ ] tell little more
proof uh
it smells like men poles more proof okay
now you just piss me off here you go
yeah that's a great way to kill people
apparently that's good now let's take
all this money tickle his money get it
ha ha okay so we're drinking yeah I
don't think you're not what kills bad
breath the ruins plumbing corrosive
agent oh [ __ ]
oh no come on can we get to the point
where's the boss I I'm pretty sure I
talked to everyone and did everything
what the hell did I miss what docks
[ __ ] kill don't [ __ ] bread docks
gotta hate bread docks they're like the
worst kind of people oh god damn it I
hate toasting flying [ __ ] all right
let's get the horse fish now I want the
horse fish no I want mr. crab I want mr.
crab mr. crab mr. quack mr. crab now god
damn it what the [ __ ] good job kids ten
points congrat two [ __ ] lesions what
is this fart appreciation
god I'm bored
ah goddamnit I'd appreciate it enough am
I not good enough for you huh
alrighty then what deaf [ __ ] can I go in
here what I want to look like this well
it's not very working well that's great
English pants you win oh this is a
kidney
ok and that's which bro yes and why we
did that
can I take the kidney no I don't need a
kidney technically good alright oh sure
spike I'm scared me alright
oh yes the gun Oh God can we just know I
oh [ __ ] the boss is coming all right
well yes but she can fly so can i oh
[ __ ] I can't okay
well give me back my pillow alright the
Pierce is here Fenella man he came
through the aquarium thing
okay there is hi quick grupa honk you
mr. crab is a perpetrator keep Queen
what no oh over here I don't know I lit
a little more what I'm a bit more mr.
crab Lisa sitting a little to your left
this isn't zilart your your other left
ah the other left goes to quick back go
back a bit
oh well there we stop yes well I'm glad
mr. crab had the perpetrator
don't kill me Polly black we've been
expecting you
I'll get right to the point please Dave
taking something of mine and so I've
taken something of yours
what what that's the vamp in spoof
they've taken some of your important
directors I may and it's imperative that
you get me back in the right hands uh my
own improvise I know you'd do well
barley I have no idea what's going to
challenge you to a game of sport should
you prove victorious I will free the
director unharmed as I won the dice roll
backstage
I'll go first I guarantee you there
won't be a one hint of foul play
what the [ __ ] is happening oh [ __ ] he's
good who run he's I'm great did you see
that he's good
it's like the sports tick a real force I
will select him hmm it said that's a
vault and that's a putt and that's I
don't even know what that don't look
down me laddie I shall go with a poor
sick friend with that one myself
yeah you know what you no way I should
do it on our [ __ ] alright um I don't
think that's gonna work
ok Eric whoa [ __ ] I was perfect than
you're doing
uh-huh there we go
I win I win very invigorating I like
your little stick okay I got it is
chilling I got my turn
get out of my way yeah say so it needs
to be on my side today I get a little I
the football I guess yeah oh come on
I really suck at this man all right
there we go just getting warmed up right
follow me and let us begin
gauntlet oh my god damn it what is it
now that was not fun I hate sports
go [ __ ] yourself oh this now we're
talking
red one no pink one please please up the
pink button yes yes oh my god what is
happening what okay sanic rings what are
you doing here sanic rings oh god what
is happening whoa whoa okay wait where
are we Ernest got it got it
I knew that perfect landing they all day
all right what's the next challenge
what's the next one tell me tell me now
next course
yes final some recreation on the
coagulant I don't know what that means
bad let's do it okay call this next Oh
God you already told me shut up
it'll coagulate yeah God get out of my
face [ __ ] all right what do you want oh
god damn it I wanted you wait Kim Chi
okay night-night not anymore this next
course will require some recreation on
the coagulant add to water all right you
can throw oh we got granny nice
everything of a lifetime Jim Weider
quite is this Oh waiver it's 64 great MA
now is this [ __ ] too weird man way
raises so good all that this is too good
Oh God
oh man the nostalgia the new style yep I
got a grave of all man I was so bad at
this [ __ ] game and I'm still terrible
god I got a win to prove that I'm worthy
oh god damn he's playing dirty okay I
got it I got it
just finish it
yes Oh high five Pam yeah that's good
you're not supposed to be able to win
this well I [ __ ] then what you gonna
do our last course you're gonna walk
through me okay Mel oh my fine
alright to the Batmobile yes miss
Batmobile all right here we go out of my
way sister out of my way oh [ __ ]
hi perfect landing my favorite is still
lick wedding quake oh [ __ ] this is a VR
[ __ ] I like that I must warn you had
quite the matrix maverick or cam like to
call me the video virtual okay whoa oh
whoa champion champion ego meter went
down yeah that's right [ __ ] call this
with this waiting that's what that's
what that's that's why it's helping your
mom coaster wave when it's [ __ ] yacht
[ __ ]
yeah let's ride said it what you're
doing
you're so kind Henry my Sophie Oh God
all right you want your trophy Machoke
[ __ ] my trophy wait I lost it I think
there it is
No get out of my [ __ ] way another
throw for me
well I have to collect trophies for the
ego all right you see a balloon a bra
balloons aren't we
I gotta get some trophies man yeah Jam
it how do I get him a trophy I don't
[ __ ] my flowers yeah okay here you got
flowers there you go yeah I guess I can
give him this you want this now well
[ __ ] what do I know
oh man oh [ __ ] so that's all for y okay
ôhe ARA watch man will not be happier
from a um well this one's okay I guess
some champagne would be in order hop in
the water okay
liquid why those [ __ ] yeah
oh really all right one drink babe
uh-huh
ah nice heart i don't know what i mean
ii creamy mm mm bet you like it that way
you dirty dirty are delicious I know
and more Scissorhands god that's kind of
awkward this is even more awkward what
that [ __ ] okay here we got finally okay
alright your ego is back in action is
that so oh he's so filled so yeah okay I
got it out save the director alright I
guess I guess I guess I can do that
oh that's a ladder here oh that's not a
ladder it's a bridge but um don't look
down okay cool um hi Birds oh god oh god
not to toasting Birds god damn I almost
died that was close man very close
alright let's save him
I don't know why he just gives me weird
my commissions and [ __ ]
oh I'm so jelly no cheap so jelly
the director is ready for you why thank
you I don't know how you surviving that
jelly but oh yeah he's director got it
got it director hi Mei it seems they've
got me suspended in some sort of a
whiskey
that sounds Garak holy whisper hey Thank
You Man
please save me before words of the whole
thing hmm I'll have complete faith that
you can do this polyline yeah well I
came this far and seeing is not a labor
secretary I already did God is wrong all
right so um how do I save him got it
okay so let's see here free the director
or krokov ocation praça fication no I
will do a crossbow to a crime scene you
million fall in my mouth now no no yeah
yeah yeah well okay I mean he just
raised a pretty good point yeah yeah
we'll pull the damn thang so people
spoke for polar yeah you're so right oh
my god I'm just tricked you okay fine
oh yeah I actually suspected that would
be a level inside a crocodile oh god
what the hell is that
yes oh sorry rittany oh no no no no no
no no no no no it can't be over now I
will play more god damage what a great
great way to roll credits
make me walk through this croc Oh stunts
by a hint octopuses and on okay you
really gotta make me crawl through a
rectum oh thank God it's not I thought
it was that's alright
vampire basketball coach Sam wail horse
brush senator bull
everyone knows vampires candy rock all
the way live studio Cobra that's pretty
impressive
I'm sorry the things they're just making
this up I'm not sure why necrophilia
games that's interesting
all right we're finally here Oh our
sincere apologies that's a gang tape
recorded here in the event that I ever
get trans mobile filing for a hard way
and you need to escape the lab answer is
my justice system provided some
specially encoded missional which
asserts an occasion perfecting money oh
and are just a warning why have a
particularly violent yeah [ __ ] plus the
flock all right well okay
also please don't harm all slic3r we
define her for pudding
there we go sounds awesome
I love that game that game was fun I
like that game oh I thought it was
William Dafoe it's like holy [ __ ] why is
he doing it I know what Jim sterling I'm
not sure if it's the same Tim sterling
anyway uh it's fun to see comedy based
games becoming more a thing I like that
they're really called microphone okay
nikka phone not really I just think like
Deadpool for example I know they're very
different games but but still that it's
a it's a game that's just funny like
laughs I love funny and save this and
it's it's good to just have fun with the
game every once in a while you know and
I really enjoyed it for that reason and
then it was just even though the stories
everywhere it's still fun to follow and
it's still fun to play all the way
through because you're always like okay
what's the next gag or what's the next
funny thing that's gonna happen it's
it's really cool really cool I I
thoroughly enjoyed this game I hope you
bros enjoyed watching it and I would
love to play whatever these guys make
next in the future
live life enjoy watching Bros as always
I really appreciate it but more than
anything I just appreciate that you both
watch my videos and they here's a
preference for you for watching it might
be wrist hey MA
Oh
you